Hey youtubers it’s charlie and this week
agents of shield introduced a new major comic
book character and stan lee made his illustrious
cameo.
It’s not a two parter, but the next episode
is a direct continuation.
which is great because I love serialized shows.
Since a lot of you in the UK won’t get to
see this for a while careful for potential
spoilers.
Marvel already announced who it is, but in
case you still don’t know I’ll save it
for the end of the video.
Let’s start with our top 5 moments and then
I’ll do my review.
Number 5 - May’s wheels up in 5.
I’m talking about the whole reverse storyline
aspect of the episode.
I thought it added a really nice touch to
the story and it was so much fun watching
what happened to May after she got knocked
off the train.
Notice that the May story was bookeneded by
Ward’s sex talk with Coulson.
I got the sense that they wanted us to visually
connect May’s intensity with her relationship
with ward.
Especially that torture scene.
It’s a nice reversal to see a female character
be so aggressive.
But I’ve always been a huge fan of ming
na.
It’s great to see her get to have so much
fun.
She has all the best action scenes on the
show.
Number 4 - stan lee cameo.
In true comic book fashion, stan lee serves
as the moral message of the episode.
His comment to coulson, you’ve made mistakes,
but you can do better is really a generic
theme for all the characters and the audience.
Particularly mike peterson’s character.
Number 3 - Strangers on a train.
Coulson and simmons epic blowout was a lot
of fun to watch.
I liked how they paid off fitz’s earlier
jokes about how she’s the queen of homework.
The look on coulson’s face when she said
prostitutes was priceless.
I can see the hashtags now.
#prostituteface
Number 2 - Skye and simmons are pretty dead.
Not one but two almost deaths.
There were maybe three game changing events
in this episode and sky and simmons were two
of those.
Simmons is just frozen as a result of the
night night gun gas, but skye is bleeding
out.
I actually expected her to manifest a power
in that post credits teaser, so it looks like
she doesn’t have any resurgence abilities.
My earlier theory was that she was a technopath.
Number 1 - Mike Peterson becomes deathlok.
I like the way they explain how he’s deathlok.
Just by using the cybernetik leg.
In the comic books, the character is more
machine than man darth vader style.
But they opted to make J august richards look
more realistic.
I’m calling that the tyrion lannister move.
When a show dramatically reduces injuries
or alterations to a character that would make
them have to wear crazy prosthetics and special
effects.
They did incorporate some of the story from
the Michael Collins deathlok in the comic
books.
He had his brain put in a cybernetic body
and was being controlled by the machine parts.
Eventually he gained control of his body and
became a SHIELD agent.
Honorable mention goes to coulson for laying
the smack down on ward during their sex talk.
He threatened to put him on emil blonsky duty
in alaska.
Remember he was the hulk villain called the
abomination.
The last person to play that character was
Tim Roth in the incredible hulk.
Let me know what your favorite moment was
and whether or not you think Skye’s power
will manifest in the next episode.
Personally seeing Mike become deathlok was
the high point of the episode.
That or couslon prostitute face.
Overall this was one of the strongest episodes
this season.
I loved the narrative structure and the way
they told a lot of the story in reverse.
And they were able to go from laugh out loud
funny on the train to almost killing the two
most loveable harmless female characters.
It’s like Joss Whedon hurting willow on
buffy, she seems so harmless so it twists
you up to watch them almost die.
Agents of SHIELD isn’t a joss whedon show,
but if you’re ever watching something joss
whedon did and you really start to love a
character.
Watch out, because they’re the one that’s
going to get hurt.
You could also call that pulling a George
RR Martin.
Stan Lee’s cameo felt appropriate.
He kind of seems like he’s been play acting
hugh hefner in all of his recent movie cameos,
but the moral message he delivered was a comic
book trope that he started.
At least in the style it was done during the
episode.
Like at the end of old GI Joe cartoons.
One of my favorite things about the episode
is how mike peterson’s arc just became one
of the most important things on the show.
He’ll be critical to them defeating the
clarivoyant.
But he started out as this throwaway extremis
cameo.
So I’m expecting a similar thing to happen
to Skye, she’s still in the middle of that
moment of horror that peterson had when he
woke up burned missing limbs.
So expect Skye’s character to undergo a
fundamental change once she recovers.
I’m hoping that means that she finds out
what her powers are and starts using them.
It’s like the show just told us, the only
way to survive is to evolve, sometimes that
means becoming a cyborg and sometimes it means
manifesting special powers.
I love science fiction so much.
Big announcement.
SHIELD is back until March 4th because of
the olympics.
When they do come back Bill paxton is guest
starring as another big shield agent.
John Garret.
In the comics he was a cyborg too.
Think of his character as being like a hardcore
version of his hicks character from aliens.
with less wisecracking.
They just made some major casting announcements
for the new flash tv show.
I’m going to be doing a special video for
that Thursday.
So subscribe to get it.
Right now click here for last week’s agents
of shield and click here to for my latest
arrow video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!